hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
the base is coming along very nicely I
am trying to get ahead of this
particular crisis here which has a good
bit of heat right down here but
thankfully everything above this line is
doing pretty okay except there's some
heat leaking through here but it's not
as bad as the heat that's leaking
through here so I think I can I think
it's fine I think it is okay so so so so
so if I can I will put insulated tile
over there just to make sure that the
box is staying inside it's not ideal cuz
I think he's cost a bit more than the
average Joe but I'm going to commit to
this anyway because I think it's
important at least it's going up kind of
cool over here which is good my
objective for now after this one
experience here now that I've got food
and oxygen and temperature relatively
good I need to start thinking about
water because I've got some backup
sources of water here and here and those
are good those are fine but the problem
is if I run out of water and I don't
have a means of filtrating water or
filtering water then I am going to die
very very quickly so he who is working
on the filtration which is the precursor
to the one that comes after that which
is the advanced filtration something
something or something like that I have
no idea what have we got skills we have
more skills
he who can you get skills please
building me Wow mee maws a good builder
me mas got a Red Hat for building that's
a cool hat alright
why can you not do this why is your
skill not good enough to do this oh you
need carrying oh I see ah so incredibly
interesting that is VI I see how this is
working now it is very interesting so
that's all good and we will get to that
eventually for right now that is good
I'm gonna do this just so it's a little
bit easier to get through all
bedrock and whatnot so now that we got a
good bit of power and now that we get a
good bit of everything else all that's
left to do now is to work on the
filtration system which is going to run
the filtering between the polluted water
and then back into the main water supply
I think I should have a separate
reclaimed water and then a main water
because the reclaimed water can be used
for irrigation purposes and like
watering the plants and the crops
because those can be disinfected
separately but if I have just a global
water thing it's not gonna be as good
and I can use the I should have a clean
water supply and then a not clean water
supply that would be ideal in my opinion
but it also might work out terribly and
be horrible and destroy everything I've
ever known and loved okay so listen I
just don't want people to have to drink
poop water is that so hard no it's not
so if I can let people drink clean water
I'll be a hero but maybe I shouldn't
worry about I mean the place is called
Pigpen afterall and I'm pretty sure
pigpens probably have a lot of poop
water whatever what does it matter who
cares it's all good we're all gonna die
anyway eventually all right insufficient
oxygen generation that's not very much
oxygen are we doing poorly
oh let's enable this building again
let's just burn a little algae I mean
what's the worst that could happen it's
not that bad I also want to be a bit
better and more cognizant which means to
be aware of and thinking about where
specific things need specific amounts of
goodies so if I can have goodies in say
this room that these plants need say
dirt fertilizer there is a storage
container in here that has those things
or at least a storage container nearby
that has those things that would save an
incredible amount of time relaying
things back and forth and make it so
that people aren't wasting too much time
it's the same logic as having
ration box in the kitchen where the food
is that way people aren't running around
trying to get food back to this box all
over the place people just go where it
needs to be and that's the end of it so
why don't I do that because I hate
myself hey Turner exosuit wearing okay
cool he want to wear an exosuit all
right coop good for you man good for you
I don't know what that means but good
for you whatever that is and whatever
you're doing hasten can someone turn
this on please
Wow bless your brain with that sweet
sweet info also it's really poopy down
here it's quite poopy it's it almost
exceptionally poopy just oh you're cute
you guys are cute you guys are pipsqueak
kids okay so cute oh my god you're cute
oh my god it's cute it's really cute so
that's there hopefully you got that I'm
gonna insulate this up we're gonna when
this breaks down I'm gonna just make a
door here so they people can get that
real quick I'm gonna purge if I'm gonna
be cognizant about these kinds of things
then it would be a who've me to put say
algae next to the places that need the
algae right so if there was say a
storage container right there and say
right here cuz that's a convenient place
to get to these algae that had algae in
it I wouldn't necessarily need them to
go running let's see I'm really using my
brain on this one but if there was algae
in here instead of just having like a
standard and then I set it so it didn't
have that much algae but it had a good
bit always on hand then it would have
the algae that I would need when I need
it you know so then people could tidy up
the algae right you cute you get what
I'm saying I feel like I'm stupid but I
feel also like I'm smart well so there's
a lot of co2 in here but I don't know if
there's anything I can do about it okay
now I don't know if people are
automatically gonna do that or if I have
to tell them specifically to tidy up
because I don't have anybody that's
specifically for tidying uni like I need
someone to be
civically at tidying oh well I mean
tinkle Tish could be a tidier
but dinkle Tish loves tinkering mmm hey
you how long in that research oh not not
close do you hear that why is there Boys
Noize right here it's the water
what is that a it's a fossil what's a
fossil
there's a lot more cells than I thought
that'd be I've never really paid
attention to this house before I'm
hearing strange sounds
okay whatever it's fine it's totally a
hundred percent fine I don't know why
I'm being weird about but it's this is
fine I don't think I'm getting enough
oxygen no definitely not enough oxygen I
thought I had plenty
apparently I have not enough I think
also because this is in a bad spot so
I'm actually gonna destroy that one I'm
gonna move it up here
and then if I need to I'll put another
one there so we can have we got we got
like oxygen coming up from the bottom
but we also need oxygen like at the top
so we could push it down and I think
that'll be good so long as I destroyed
this because I think that's also getting
a little in the way so that's gonna get
destroyed eventually but that's not
overloading the power just yet yeah
we're good we're good we're good we're
very good hey people put out G in here
hey that's good hey that's pretty cool
everything's looking kind of up how's
the temperature doing still kind of
toasty these are getting hot which is
weird
I didn't think that they would get hot
I see fan uses ice to dissipate a small
amount of heat um converts water to ice
I don't have ice so I can't just use
water anymore in it I gotta use ice that
makes sense I guess but also it's a bit
more of a problem because I can't just
onda man make ice cuz that produces heat
and then it kind of feed the whole
purpose of what we were doing over here
but I'm just saying that I think that
maybe there's a bit of a problem there
and I wasn't thinking properly so
eventually I gotta cool this down but
for right now it's okay the insulating
is not doing exactly that I found it
maybe I need to put another layer there
like I like layers let's layer it what's
the worst that could happen like a
double layer airlock or something like
that no whatever gives them something to
do do we need another person the answer
is no but
here I go anyway apparently bristle ball
bristle berries Oh Oh
you are actually a farmer and you're
you're a farmer that is a slowly
you are actually you even look like a
tired slow simple farmer oh good old
dumpling get it near you brick oh good
old Dublin you are so simple but I love
you you just love farm and ain't you
just a peach
ain't you just peach you just a peach I
love you good good old dumpling an evil
baby face the two farmers
two sides you guys are so perfect it's
evil baby face a good old dumpling two
sides of the same coin oh what's gonna
be up here Oh guys you need to pick your
side all these grew up wow they're still
cute which one are you evil baby face or
good old dumpling I know which one I am
but I ain't gonna tell yous we're doing
on oxygen now we better yeah that's
better
that's definitely getting better there's
not a lot of like air flow through some
of these places so that's why it's
getting a little non distributed but
it's doing okay until I get to the point
where I can actually like put air ducts
where they need to be I'm just gonna add
a few airflow tiles to let rooms breathe
just a little more oh I need to give
good old dumpling up bed don't I know
he's not gonna be with everybody else
but frankly I don't know if he needs to
be with everyone else you know he does
you know actually let's not put one in
the poop room because that's not good no
we're doing our research still a little
more to go but then we'll get filtration
then we get water going and then we
won't die that's the dream just not
dying you know actually the the
insulation is working it looks like the
temperature is either evening out from
where it was or at least going down a
little bit which is better than the
situation that was happening before that
is still getting toasty refined carbon
excuse me
yeah what gasps find carbon gasps
breathable gasps oxygen I'm sorry you
might be confused I don't think that's
what you think it means oh there goes
purified from raw coal I'm not sure what
happened there but great you just keep
heating up buddies you just keep getting
nice and toasty okay so that project is
done the oxygen is getting way better
oh yeah the airflow tile is gonna help
pass all that through get the I need to
eventually get the toxic but thankfully
I think it's the same research no it's
different research where is
decontamination that's what it is
okay I need decontamination because
there is a lot of polluted oxygen just
literally everywhere it's because these
things are everywhere I gotta now I
remember why I didn't necessarily want
those going straight up like that but
it's also a factor of the fact that we
don't necessarily have someone tidying
everything up and we definitely don't
have places for everything so it is what
it is eventually I will get like a big
old tidy command going on but I don't
have any places to put it just yet it's
not necessarily gonna be the best maybe
for the time being I will you know what
actually I will I'm for the time being
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna make
storage bins for literally everything
right now and see what happens hey we
did it we did we did okay water water
filtration okay we got the filtration
ooh water see bull ethanol stupid we can
make we can make booze we're gonna get
draw I'm gonna treat these duplicants
right we're gonna get him crunky drunk
so water sieve though it takes a lot of
power to do this and ideally I would not
put this directly back in considering
this is loaded up with every type of
bacteria but that being said what was
what what is it what is it what is that
floral scent
for your scent I said have a floral
scent is affirm the bristle blossoms
like that way they're sneezing they're
allergic to I didn't know that could be
a thing you could be allergic to it wit
but that's so cool but that's also so
weird you are disgusting
who is that you can't you get your ass
oh alright whatever it doesn't matter um
I'm gonna put this for all acceptance
everything except organic we're not
gonna have it be organic but everything
else is fair game
copy that to everything and I'm gonna
set the world's biggest sweep or I do
bye pause they didn't mean to pause I'm
sorry I forgot the world's biggest sweep
command here we go we're sweeping it
we're cleaning up boink
oh yeah now that is what I'm talking
about
oh yeah let's speed it up because that's
gonna take a while but this is good
believe it or not it is in fact good
okay this is gonna take a while so I'm
gonna have you guys watch good old
dumpling make sure they're up to you
know not not good but you know make sure
they're up to good cuz they might not be
up where are you going
a rotten bristle bear are we losing food
to rot
they don't have refrigerator yet so I
guess we would be I'll be back
wait why are we dead why did we stop who
did anyone die oh they're not even done
sweeping we were sweeping so good well
this is some baloney this is some
felonious baloney okay so we finished
our research there and I stupidly I
guess didn't set another research while
I was away cuz I'm stupid why I need to
get decontamination so I'm gonna get
that so that we can get the poop air out
of here because there's a lot of poop
air I don't know why there's so much
poop air but there is a lot of poop here
okay we don't need any more people we're
gonna keep it at eight for a good long
while
huh flitting three puffs --let's that's
a lot of puffs lights I'll do the puff
woods give me a puff once I'm gonna kill
him anyway for food but whatever I
should set up a ranching area I wasn't
even building
why was I'm not even building a
refinement area I need the water Steve
okay we're gonna do a water sieve I am
going to set up a separate reclaim above
water because I love
myself and I love my duplicants and I
won't let them swim around in muck I
won't do it I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna make them swim around in muck they
deserve better finally starting to get
into the plumbing aspect of this so we
need a pump Oh God we're gonna need a
separate power supply for this I know
boy here we go okay goes here to the end
and then the out is gonna flow to here
okay you need 120 120 watts actually
it's better than I thought it was well
then actually we can hook that up they
drop the power requirement on that
didn't they because it used to be way
way more power than that okay but that's
good that's good that means I can
utilize a lot more than I once did I
mean the the pump still ah the pumps
still 240 nevermind I think it was it
was a pipe dream I'm never gonna be able
to pay all right I don't have any drop
Junction things there either whatever
they were called they weren't called
drop junctions I know that transformers
that's what it was
yet alright we got a long way to go for
that but let's worry about that later
let's just create a separate power
supply that's gonna power that because I
don't have time or the brainpower or the
energy to do that so I'm gonna set up a
small separate subsystem that's only
gonna power that water pump because I
just don't have time to make more than
that happen so I need to set up a
separate thing boom so that is a
separate power system and I'm gonna give
it its own battery so that we don't need
to constantly have people going to that
and then once that's there this will be
powered and everything will be hunky and
everything will be dory and if
everything's not hunky and everything is
not dory then I'm gonna blow everything
up because I'm angry and I lash out okay
so it's not powered yet but it will be
powered as soon as someone hops in that
bad boy and then once I get to the point
where I can have transformers I will do
that but for now this is good and it's
gonna drop into there which is a big
priority oh yeah people are still
sweeping aren't they not that I need
them to sweep but whatever okay here we
go
and bada bing I think I saw some flirty
I think I saw flirting okay good
so that's getting done there okay good
this is going surprisingly good there is
some heat leak from right here so I'm
just gonna go ahead and destroy that and
then replace it with just insulating
tile there that way we don't have to
worry about that but yeah that's that's
pretty good this is going shockingly
well and and I think the temperature is
actually going down here and 100% sure
why it would be going down but I think
it's going down a little bit at least
and then we're getting water here we can
put a separate pump here just for this
water here okay cool and then we'll have
a separate water for this ooh good thing
I did when I did that we are in trouble
we have a lot less water than I thought
we had thought we had a lot of water but
turns out it turns out that it was that
was a lie okay good huh
Hey look evil baby face what do you want
to do how about evil baby face evil baby
face is gonna be the rancher and then
good old dumpling you know what actually
evil baby face no good old dumpling
needs to be that no evil baby face you
actually likes excavation it's a good
point that's a good point it is what
they like do they get bonus morale if
they do what they like doing I don't
know
good old dumpling likes farming they
couldn't do both I guess
yeah we'll make you evil evil baby face
do what he likes like why not oh you
can't do that yeah okay whatever
okay you are gonna be more research I
don't care if you don't like it you're
gonna do it ten gold touch you do what
you love but you can't because you're
not at that okay you're gonna you're
gonna do this though and beardy you're
gonna get this so you can get mechanics
which you love it's important to do what
you love I think we've got it looks so
nice over there why is it so nice and
blue and lit up and beautiful it's
beautiful here so pretty this whole
hallway is really pretty
it's very aesthetically pleasing right
here oh there's too much polluted oxygen
though there's a lot of polluting oxygen
look oh you are disgusting oh you are
gross oh you all get instantly gross
that's horrible that's okay that's a
problem we're gonna need to we're gonna
need to do it we're gonna need to do
something about that because we got to
put like a leg up like a washbasin oh
crap there we go okay and then people
are gonna wash their hands on the way
out that way anytime they get I know
it's a little bit of a problem just
because they obviously it's a problem
but it's it's a little bit of preventive
that's gonna go a long way okay there we
go and then only to the left okay and
then this off with this and hey we got
the Sanitation thing right we got the
deodorizer okay reducing disease spread
put one right there cheer okay I know
this is like the episode of the stink
and the episode of the stink is not
going good for me in terms of like
everything being horribly filled with
pollution but if you think about it it's
also the episode the
episode of the omelets yeah give us
armlets yeah of course give us omelets
why wouldn't we get up yes omelets
that's great okay cool uh all right so
you've maxed out that so what else could
we get I guess you know you do some
building sometimes so I guess you could
do that sure yeah well why not right
who's me MA also building you sometimes
need supply for that as well so you can
have supply okay uh I definitely should
have some deodorizer here but I wouldn't
want to put it there because it's not
I'm gonna pull sneaky on him watch this
I'm gonna pull a sneaky on you okay so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put this
right there but deodorizer right there
and then I'm gonna put the other compost
right there and I forgot about this
thing way over here this should not be
there that's not in a place I can
control and there's a lot of polluted
water over there maybe it was a dumb
idea to get all these do the big giant
sweep command because that seems like
something that not working out too well
for me right now and we're also not
making enough oxygen for some reason and
I don't know why because it looks like
we're doing good on oxygen but
apparently we're not so it's because
it's annoying me I'm gonna cancel all
the kids all that that's better
okay research why aren't we research
anything let's get agriculture because
we are wasting a lot to rot and we don't
want rot rot not good if we can avoid
rot that'd be ideal
you know while I'm at it I can actually
make this musher be on this separate
circuit which would help out a good bit
so I'm gonna do is I'm I deconstruct
that deconstruct this and I'm gonna make
this wire bridge to their cool this is
going surprisingly good and then we can
finally finish this project which was
forever ago we got water guys it's going
good
can you believe it I certainly cannot oh
that was one person that we know without
washing their hands
okay whatever what a little sickness is
nothing compared to not being sick so
that's pretty good it's nothing I can do
about it right now I need to make
another bed just for duty
dumpling for dumpy-dumpy 'he's gonna
have a good night's sleep that's for
sure so I've got the deodorizers there
for some reason there's some theater
ization
it needs to be done here little airflow
tile right Brett cheer get rid of that
and then pop of this on that carbon
skimmer I don't need that unless
something yeah why would you do a carbon
skimmer when you can make an algae
terrarium and get just as much because I
mean and all honestly that would be
supremely more effective right
Oh God we are running out of water there
okay let's just destroy all of these
because now they're none of them are
doing any good and all so let's go ahead
and tap this one because I we are
running out of water
oh uh mush bars we need to stop making
that because we are actually losing
water from that so let's put that on
hold for now because we got some food
now let's I think we need to make
another layer of food production and
let's go ahead and do one of these
maneuvers actually not that not that air
flow air flow and we're gonna move this
over here we don't really need it but
you know it's it's something good to
have and it's getting in the way the
door that I'm gonna put right there we
don't have enough Brier blossom but we
do have a lot of meal wood let's just go
ahead and make meal wood this would be
the meal wood level
I know briar blossoms take water which
is another place where water is also
just kind of going away now they need 20
water per cycle which is not a lot that
is not a lot but it's not something that
gets recycled that is something that
just goes away so to be perfectly honest
I think the best bet right now is meal
lice those people are sneezing up a
storm from those things oh well okay
hopefully that's gonna help out with
food and once we get the research done
for the refrigerator then we're gonna
get the refrigerator in there we'll can
stop wasting food we still be moderately
better oh god people are getting food
poisoning all over the place Oh God from
breathing germ filled polluted oxygen
I'm doing my best it's getting better
it's just not quite there just yet we
need to put a deodorizer like
right here or something I mean it's it's
everywhere but at least we can do a
little bit to kind of combat it why do I
even breach these at all we don't need
them to be bridged so why am i bridging
them huh I don't know I'm terribly
stupid I can just have different pumps
at different levels so that they're
always ready to go just in case we get
to the level that it needs to be I
suppose I'll be smart wouldn't it but
I'm not smart is the thing oh [ __ ] why
is it how long has that been like that
how long has that been like that there's
a lot of problems but there's also a lot
of solutions so hopefully we're gonna
run out of problems we're gonna start
filling up with solutions right quick
but I'm all out of time for this episode
for now I'm gonna put a deodorizer right
there right there eventually but there
for now I'm a little snooze well let
them snooze because they need to snooze
because they need to build up their
strength for the next time that I ask
them to do something horrible and
incredible so thank you everybody so
much for watching this is going well but
I am in a constant panic at every moment
and I need to get ranching up before
these eggs explode into sheep things
that are gonna eat all my meal would be
the way thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]